so this is a spray
that you spray in your into most
intimate area [__] and your butt in the
dick in the bottles everything oh dick
and balls yeah everything man woman
everybody it's called p-u-z-z-y [__]
yeah
it was because I was like doing concerts
and you know we sweat the but what is
the butt what is the butt it's two
things doing this the whole day the
cheeks are rubbing together all day so
it smells that smells that stinks if if
we need deodorant and and our arms are
getting some fresh air sometimes imagine
the butt there's they're locked in the
cave this is a nice odor this is nice
it's not too strong so you don't spray
[__] right away oh you spray it exactly
when I put deodorant after deodorant I
put the [__]
you call poozie yeah and then it smells
good for 12 for half a day and if you're
out and about you keep it in your purse
and if you take a dump somewhere what a
steak a dump I don't know um Duty make a
duty you know make a bowel movement poop
oh yes I do take a [__] and everywhere
anywhere you do like it you don't care I
don't you are a woman who's open about
be the fact that we are animals and we
have smells and things like that and I
don't like this mouse and you don't like
the smells and this is a product that
you use exactly wow
and you speak you spend hours like half
a day smelling great because at the end
of the day if right now you get your
finger you put in your ass yeah and you
smell it's gonna smell like ass right
but if you have this no it smells like
that did you tattoo your ass yes I did
what should say love and pain in in red
you guys go nuts when like you know I'm
talking about your intimacy for them to
see if they really gotta search
they need to start it's not inside there
it's it's there it's inside it's inside
there you need to see they need to that
is love I mean they don't they don't
have they don't notice because it's so
small I was with my dad getting drunk
with who your dad my father yeah we were
drinking and we wanted to do he wanted
to do a tattoo and he was scared it was
like oh that hurts that heart I said I'm
gonna we're gonna google right now
what's the most painful play part of the
body right and I'm gonna get a tattoo
right there and we were drunk so when we
googled it was the ass so that's why I
did it oh the S is the most painful yeah
no kidding and so in front of your dad
in the inside of your ass he was telling
me if it was looking good or not
having fun I envy that because he's my
best friend my dad wouldn't even throw a
baseball with me let alone go get a
tattoo in my ass his
crazy